some of the IDF forces said we didn't
know what we were shooting at we didn't
we didn't know and we just started uh
shooting randomly we didn't know what to
do because they were so disorganized now
I I would admit and it's very true that
the MOs caused a great deal of confusion
and through the whole IDF into a
complete uh quandry they didn't know
what was going on uh and so they
actually committed some acts of violence
against uh inadvertently their own
people you see this is why I don't go
anywhere near I think that's not true I
think what you're saying is false okay
well I'll have to I'll have to follow up
with that right so so this is I I take
this is this is this is the issue I take
with the Israel palestin conflict is all
is all the lies and misinformation that
are spread all the time and uh but you
suspect I've heard I've heard I've heard
nothing about Israel bombing its own
villages we no not whole Villages I did
not say that it houses in villages
houses I'm not saying accidentally shot
people on uh on the street